[Music]
march is problem gambling awareness
month
and we know it's an issue that not only
impacts the gambler but the entire
family
certified life coach adam javlin tackled
his own addiction and he wants to help
others with theirs
he says a stigma attached with addiction
of all kinds is weakness
or lack of willpower and he says once
you understand it's an addiction and
obsession of the mind that this person
is
sick not bad then he says it changes the
dynamic of the relationship and you can
help that individual
the key he says is to get the entire
family involved
it's extremely important i even work
with dr
rob kelly the number one doctor in
addiction
and he won't take on clients unless the
family gets involved
and the reason is is that we need
everybody speaking the same language at
the same time
he says it's important to have the
family all together to be able to speak
to the addict on how their addiction is
affecting all of you
he says to look into treatment centers
that encourage a 12-step
gambler's anonymous movement and an
interventionist that you can trust
adam of course helps people through this
challenge as well you can reach him at
adamjavelin.com christian